ten tenten tenten tenten tenten tenten
tenten a janitor
nananananananananananana ttan ttan ttan
ttan ttan ttan ttan ttan ttan ttan ttan
ttan ttan ttan ttan ttan the Bourne
Identity guys Jason Bourne is coming out
in July and I'm a humongous fan of the
Bourne franchise
I love the Bourne films I've had a lot
of fun watching them again because I
feel like reviewing them I want to give
you guys more in-depth reviews of the
Bourne trilogy than I did before
starting with the Bourne Identity
directed by Doug Liman who later went on
to direct edge of tomorrow the role of
Jason Bourne was well known to people
who had enjoyed Robert Ludlum's books
before and when they cast Matt Damon in
this role the guy from Good Will Hunting
and courage under fire that didn't go
over too well and what have I always
said in videos about casting
announcements nobody likes anything
that's ever announced ever I remember
back in 2002 people were losing their
shit people were so pissed off that the
little skinny guy from courage under
fire was going to play a badass spy
Jason Bourne and well they were wrong if
you've never seen the Bourne films
before these upcoming reviews are going
to contain some spoilers I highly
suggest seeing them though that's your
warning this movie presents a fantastic
mystery you have this guy who washes up
on a boat somewhere he's been shot in
the back twice he has no idea who he is
yet as the film progresses he suddenly
finds himself gaining skills that he had
no idea he had he has a bank account
number lodged into his hip and a little
metal device when he goes to that Bank
he finds guns and passport information
and tons of money he has no idea who he
is
and this film is about that journey so
it's just as interesting for us as an
audience because the only information
that we get really comes from Jason
Bourne learning about himself were the
most ingenious things about the Bourne
Identity though is that when it cuts
back to the people who are looking for
him who are hunting him the CIA and all
his other secret agent people Chris
Cooper and Brian Cox the way they talked
about born you get that he has a
reputation but you aren't told what he
is an assassin you start to figure that
out as the film progresses but you can
actually go back and re-watch the movie
and everything that the CIA
are saying make sense it's not like
they're speaking secretly so that the
audience doesn't figure out that borns
an assassin the way they talk about
Bourne builds anticipation for who he is
makes you sort of feel afraid of this
guy but they don't come out and say who
he is
so the film's reveal isn't ruined but
the way they are speaking about this guy
still makes sense because it's not they
just go around smoking cigarettes going
yeah a boy that Jason Bourne assassin
man we got to take care of that assassin
don't we we really got to take care of
that Jason Bourne assassin they would
never do that and so it works that
they're walking around speaking of him
as almost like this ghost that
everyone's afraid of even existing
whenever this guy comes on camera
everyone's like holy shit that's Jason
Bourne oh my god get everyone out of
there now and so when it cuts back to
people who know who Jason Bourne is and
you see the fear in their eyes just the
mention of his name it's such a great
way to set up a compelling hero let's
talk about the action sequences because
the action sequences in the Bourne
franchise are sort of a mixed bag I tend
to hate shaky cam and a lot of that is
due to the fact that many mini
filmmakers have no idea how to use it
there are a select few people who
understand the art of handheld cam
versus shakey cam and people tend to
confuse these two art forms handheld cam
is not the same as shaky cam shaky cam
masks poor stunt work it hides an
actor's inability or directors inability
to film an action scene competently
handheld kamla man often utilizes in his
action films is completely different and
the Bourne Identity the first one there
really isn't that much shaky cam per se
there's a lot of handheld cam and it's
edited very quickly the median shot
length in this movie is not very long at
all and you get the sense that
everything is moving at this very
frenetic pace because that's how our
hero feels too in his brain he's feeling
so broken and everything is fragmented
and so the fact that the movies are also
filmed that way is extremely clever but
going back to the camera style of the
Bourne Identity in particular doug liman
did a lot of really interesting things
with this movie he breaks rules he
breaks the 180 rule if you don't know
what the one
rule is it's that the camera always
stays on this pivoting 180 degree angle
when it cuts back and forth between two
people who are talking or two people who
are fighting and it gives you the sense
of where people are located in a scene
for instance if I am sitting here
talking to someone over there when it
cuts the way to the person he's going to
be sitting there looking over there from
the other angle that's the 180 rule doug
liman I believe intentionally breaks
that rule in this movie quite often and
it's just a theory of mine but I think
that's the way Lyman approached most of
the directing in this movie there isn't
a single aspect of it it feels Hollywood
iced it all feels as if it's happening
within the moment when I rewatched the
Bourne Identity it felt like I was
watching events that took place and
that's my best compliment for this movie
I got talked about Matt Damon okay we
all know he's great as Jason Bourne when
this movie came out he blew me the fuck
away he is fantastic in this film with
the action scenes with the dramatic
scenes you feel for this guy you
understand him you feel as if you're on
this ride with him and it's chemistry
with the girl he meets Murray is
fantastic and she is so good in this
film their relationship feels natural
she's like the only person he knows and
so they create this relationship with
one another that's so sweet but again is
not Hollywood eyes she doesn't walk
around in a bikini the camera doesn't
pan up her body sensually these are just
two people on the run and it feels so
real the action is so visceral it's so
exciting there's a great car chase
sequence with Paul Oakenfold Ready
Steady Go playing in the background the
fight scenes are brutal pretty intense
for a pg-13 and they're all done very
well and again it doesn't feel like
Hollywood eyes action it feels like a
guy who just knows his shit and can take
you down if he chooses to
I view all of the Bourne trilogy a
little bit differently and I'll get more
into those as I review supremacy and
ultimatum but the Bourne Identity is a
very good action thriller but to me it's
the best character piece of the three
it's the one that really makes you feel
for this guy the most I'm going to give
the Bourne Identity an A
so please stay tuned for my reviews of
The Bourne Supremacy and the Bourne
Ultimatum I've already reviewed the
Bourne Legacy in the past and I'm not
going to be refilling facts I don't want
to watch that movie again it sucks
that's the honest truth if you want to
watch my review the Bourne Legacy it's
up now but I do want to do more in-depth
reviews of the original Bourne trilogy
since I love them so much stay tuned as
well for my upcoming review of Jason
Bourne next July because I'm going to do
something special my friends and I and
my wife we're gonna film a badass Jason
Bourne skit I really want to do
something fun and we're going to do that
for the Jason Bourne review so look
forward to that guys that's going to be
next July of course when the film comes
out you guys the best thank you so much
as always for watching or views of
supremacy and ultimatum coming up very
soon if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck menage